I'll tell you one of the things that I
was super excited about when you were
announced in this cast I'm serious you
know yes don't spoil you some more you
know why because you kick so much ass in
Game of Thrones it's like to watch you
on that show and to see what you do with
everything just how powerful a character
you are in that show you watch your
short fighting in that it looks like
that the blaster is our weapon of choice
were you disappointed at all that you
didn't get to do sword fighting or was
the blaster a nice change in peace
I think variety is the spice of life
just for you how was it we mentioned
Game of Thrones here we mentioned it has
a very medieval feel to it that show
what I've seen so far in these trailers
with the Knights of Ren and there's
castles there's castles being blown out
it has like a medieval medieval feel to
it
were you surprised when you signed on
that you know it start Wars - you were
you expecting to see that kind of
medieval field I think that JJ's been
very open about how he has wanted to
make things realistic and how he has
wanted to preserve the authenticity of
the film's that we love so everything
that is used in the film as far as my
knowledge I was in awe at the level of
realism so everything that you'd see on
those incredible sets the level of
detail was really phenomenal and it felt
real and so that's kind of my point is
that it doesn't matter what sort of
context it comes from it feels very real
and and it has a modernity to it but all
these movies you felt like this universe
has been lived in and then it was real
and everything you see in the trailer
thus far is exactly what you're saying
now in regards to phasma and I know
there's only so much that you can say
can you tell me anything about
what her maybe her agenda is I know that
I see her with with hawks and I see her
then maybe someplace with kylo Ren can
you tell me anything about the dynamic
at all there what I can tell you is that
captain phasma is the captain of the
stormtroopers that she is a member of
the first order and part of the dark
side the rest you just gotta wait for
that movie to come out I want to wait
for the fandango we would like to
present you with this gift card
specialist cards thank you all right Oh
No thank you so much I'm so excited
look at this right there that's a lot
that's good stuff and you deserve it I
can't wait for this I can't wait for
phasma I can't wait for you and I'll see
you at the premiere
oh darling thanks so much
you